So, widget-overrideable functions. We've talked a little bit about the widget editor itself.
Let's go a bit more detail into the blueprint-y side of things.
The key functions to be aware of.
OnInitialize, Preconstruct, Construct, Tick and Destruct.
You could get a long way with all of these really.
Preconstruct is a function we've talked a little bit about already.
This essentially gets called as soon as our widget gets created.
This is similar to Construct, which we'll talk about in a second.
But this function, Preconstruct, gets called both at design time in the game and in editor.
So, that has a lot in common with synchronized properties.
We've kind of already highlighted the discrepancy there,
that Preconstruct is only for user widgets and downwards and is exposed to Blueprint.
Synchronized properties is anything from UWidget downwards
and it also has the burden of responsibility of funneling data down from the UWidget
down to the SWidget.
So, in any pre-existing Unreal widget, you'll see they have a synchronized properties value
and they are sending data down to the SWidget.
So, it has additional stuff that it's doing.
But other than that, they have a lot in common there.
Yes, OnInitialized is called as the widget is created
and it has absolutely no correlation for whether or not the widget is actually displayed.
So, an important thing about Construct and Preconstruct
is that these will be called when our widget actually gets put onto screen.
So, Construct is kind of the closest thing to an active begin play function.
It's kind of like our widget has started.
But a kind of important caveat is that it's very typical that Construct might get called multiple times.
So, every time you add a widget to Viewport,
it's Construct and it's Preconstruct will get called.
Every time you remove a widget from the Viewport,
we get a Destruct get called.
So, this is kind of like equivalent-ish to our end play.
But again, a widget that gets added to screen or removed from screen multiple times
will have Construct and Destruct called multiple times.
If you really want something a little bit closer to the real functionality of begin play,
which is this thing gets called once,
with the caveat that in multiplayer scenarios,
with things becoming out of relevancy, begin play might get called multiple times.
So, I'm slightly flipping there.
The onInitialize is a function that gets called only once.
And it has absolutely no bearing on whether or not that widget gets displayed,
a widget could never get added to screen.
It's onInitialize that gets called the moment that widget gets created.
It's important to mention that onInitialize is called very, very early in the process.
So early, in fact, that if you have variables that are marked as exposed on spawn,
those variables won't even have their exposed on spawn value set yet on Initialize.
If that's a little bit confusing, I'm not completely sure what I mean by that.
Let's actually just do a quick demonstration.
So, if we go to our widget, this is just our new widget.
I'm just going to delete all the content we put in there,
because we just don't need it.
We can leave the visuals, that doesn't matter too much.
So, if we do our pre-construct, we do a print string here,
you can see we've got the bool for whether or not we're in design time.
We're going to do our construct, and we're going to say pre-construct here,
construct here, destruct, you can see where this is going, and initialize.
Okay, so, if we were to add this widget to our screen,
you can see all of those things will get called.
I've got a kind of server setup running here, let me just go into standalone.
What I'm going to do is I'm actually going to do begin play,
I'm going to promote that to a variable,
and what I'll do is I'll just quickly put in a debug key here.
So, debug key one, and I'm just going to do a flip-flop.
Very useful in control flow function,
but you're just quickly trying to test things.
And so, on the flip, we're going to put the widget on screen,
on flop, these are not official terms.
We're going to remove it from parent,
we're just going to remove it from the screen.
So, let's just see what happens.
So, when we begin play, you see on initialize gets called,
and then I added the screen, pre-construct and then construct get called,
so obviously the kind of lower one is being done first,
you can see pre-construct is getting called first, destruct is called,
add it again, pre-construct and construct.
The object isn't getting deleted, it's not changing,
but it's getting called multiple times, right?
But the other element to kind of bear in mind here,
again, initialize only getting called once,
is that if you do expose on spawn,
so you might not be familiar with this,
but this is a concept not unique to UMG, but it's also for any actors.
If you have some data that you kind of want to be,
you know, something you can set as that thing gets created,
I'm just going to do like some string,
and mark it instance editable and expose on spawn,
you'll see that when I go to my level blueprint,
if something is marked as expose on spawn,
if I refresh this node,
you can see I now get to pass in some value for some string to be,
so I'm just going to type in some cool phrase,
and if we print that on our construct,
instead of saying construct, we print what the cool phrase is,
or even our pre-construct,
when I press one, they both say some cool phrase,
so clearly, that value has been passed in.
However, if I were to do the same thing with our initialize,
it's, well, actually, what I'm going to do is I'm going to give it some initial value,
because otherwise you're going to see nothing,
so I'm just going to do ee,
and when I play, you see it says ee,
and that's because initialize is called so early in the flow
that it's before our,
even before our expose on spawn variables
have been kind of properly assigned,
so just an important thing to bear in mind
when you're working with some of this stuff
is that initialize is very powerful,
but it's literally, you should really only be setting internal data.
You can't rely on data necessarily coming into the widget
because it's called so early
that that data may not even be valid yet.
Just a little thing to bear in mind.
And then the last element here is tick,
which is very synonymous with this tick we're already kind of used to.
This is a thing that's called once per frame.
Unlike actor tick, same as construct,
this tick is only called whilst that widget is on screen,
so if I can just quickly demonstrate that.
If we go to our widget tick,
I'm just going to say hello because I'm lazy.
You can see it's peering lots.
I take it off screen, and it's not printing anymore,
and I put it back on screen, and it's printing a lot again.
If you're wondering where that other hello came from,
that was actually our initialize,
so I'll, yeah, that wasn't the tick for having once.
So, yeah, that's kind of everything
about the kind of initial core functions,
core events to kind of know about.
Obviously, these all have C++ equivalents,
so these are all called native on initialize,
native on reconstruct, native reconstruct,
native construct, native tick, native destruct,
so do exactly the same things but in C++.
Then we've got some input functions.
This is kind of just a small subset of what's available,
but we'll just kind of quickly discuss some of them.
So we have mouse put button up and down,
so down is quite self-explanatory
as the button goes down, so as you click in,
mouse button up or key up is as these buttons go up,
and they pass in some kind of data
about what the widget's current geometry is,
information about the mouse or button event,
so what key was clicked,
where was your cursor on screen, that kind of thing.
A couple of important things to bear in mind
is that mouse button events
will probably only be called when the cursor is on,
so there's a variable you can set in the player controller
to say show mouse cursor,
but also they'll only trigger
when there is actually kind of physical widget geometry
under the cursor,
so even if you set this widget as a focus,
the mouse events will only be viable
when the mouse is intersecting visible,
and I'm not talking about visible as in the player can see it,
I mean with the visibility setting of visible,
i.e. they can be hit by tracing,
to make it completely clear what I mean,
whenever you're dealing with widgets,
there is a visibility setting here,
and we have a couple of different settings,
we have not hit testable,
which is the kind of standard setting
for things that might contain other things,
but shouldn't be hittable themselves,
either from navigation or from clicking,
we have hidden, so it occupies space,
but you can't see it,
collapsed, which means it doesn't occupy space
and you can't see it,
and last of all we have visible,
which means this thing does occupy space,
you can see it,
and it can be hit,
either by trying to navigate around the screen
with your gamepad or your keyboard,
and it can also be clicked on,
so it's only when your cursor is over something that is visible,
that is part of that widget,
that your mouse events will get called,
sorry, accidentally opening applications there,
we have onMouseMove,
so that's whilst your mouse is moving
within geometry of that widget,
onKeyDown does the same thing,
it doesn't have that same requirement
for the visible geometry,
but onKeyDown likely won't get called in your widget
unless your widget is the focus of a player,
we'll talk a little bit about focus in a little bit,
but the short explanation is that
when you want something to receive,
keyboard or gamepad input,
the easiest thing to do is set that widget
to be the focus of that player controller,
which you can just do through a very easy function,
you can just go like this,
I put a widget on screen,
and I just say setFocus,
and that's the kind of simplest way to do it,
there are other kind of caveats to bear in mind,
but I have now set this widget to be focused,
that widget could then set children of it
to be focused as well,
but that's the easiest way to say that
now this can probably receive,
the only kind of other thing to bear in mind
is that widget actually has to be marked as focusable,
so if I went to my new widget,
you would need to go to the designer,
to a hierarchy here,
and just make sure that it is actually a focusable widget,
so you just need this all ticked,
and now that object is likely to receive onKeyDown
and functions onKeyDown, onKeyUp,
and then onPreviewKeyDown,
so this is, whereas there is a mouse button down,
mouse button up, key down, key up,
previewKeyDown only exists for key down,
there is no preview mouse down,
there is no preview key up,
it's only for key down,
and whereas the standard functionality
for all of these input events
is input kind of funnels to the deepest,
most focused widget that it possibly can,
and if that widget can then essentially respond to that event,
you can see we can return either a handled
or an unhandled response to this input to say,
oh, I did something with this input
or I didn't do something with this input,
it doesn't matter if you actually did,
but this is just saying to the system,
oh, maybe you should look elsewhere
for someone else who can deal with this,
this is essentially saying,
you know, look elsewhere or don't,
handled means I've done it,
you don't need to look any further,
unhandled means no,
maybe kind of bubble this up the chain,
and so what that will do is
the input will go to the deepest,
most focused widget,
and if the input is unhandled,
then naturally the input will filter up
the actual widget hierarchy
to the kind of next widget up
to see if it can handle that input
and so on and so forth.
On previewKeyDown,
it kind of gets called before any of that stuff
and gives widgets further up the hierarchy
the opportunity to kind of steal
that input before it gets to the widgets below it
so that you can kind of do
a kind of top-down parent overrules child
kind of thing in case you need that functionality
in any places.
So that's just a little bit of a taster
of all the things available.
You should absolutely look into the user widget
to kind of get a more full picture.
There's a lot of caveats with all of these things,
so definitely look into it some more,
but those are kind of some key functions
to just be aware of.